BOB MEESE: So, hi.
Thank you.
My name is Bob Meese.
I manage the games
business development
group for Google Play.
And I'm going to
present to you today
on best practices for
success on Google Play.
The guys this morning,
the first section,
they focused mainly on
our newest products,
what we're launching right
now or very recently.
And I'm going to
focus on some things
that have been around
maybe a little bit longer,
but that we're
really excited about
and that we, as
the partner team,
are encouraging
developers to adopt.
And so first,
before we start too,
I really want to
thank everybody.
This is a great turnout today.
There's a lot of different
ways to spend your time at GDC.
And we're really
grateful for you
guys to spend it here with us.
So thank you.
All right.
So heroes has been our theme.
And us, as the partner team,
it's very easy to convince us
that you guys are
all the heroes.
Our job is working
with all of you,
bringing all of
your great feedback
into the team at Google Play
and Google more broadly,
and working with
you to adopt all
of these exciting new products
that are being announced.
As the partner team, I'll focus
on five things here today.
So the first brief section
will be on benchmarking
and on working with more of you.
Our team has grown over
the past several years.
And so it used to
be the case we were
working with some developers.
Now, we're working with
more and more developers.
We want to be working with as
many developers as possible.
And so we'll talk about that.
In terms of the
products, we'll focus
on store listing experiments.
It has been out since
Google I/O last year,
but has been very successful.
Pre-registration is another
thing that we'll talk about.
Play games services is another.
And then finally,
talking a bit further
on in the future in terms of new
technologies and new platforms.
So first on benchmarking
and working with all of you.
So retention benchmarking is
something to keep in mind.
And so this is public data
that was launched last year
in terms of what the retention
curves for top games look like.
And I bring this up just
because as mobile games,
as the market
evolves and matures,
many times when you're trying
to get a player into your game,
you're competing with
what that person is
doing right now, which is
probably playing other games.
And so it's really
important to keep
in mind what your
metrics need to look
like to make a
successful long-term game
and having that discipline
even before you're launching.
And so we're increasingly
working with developers
to help them have these best
practices, understanding what
is the state of the art and what
are the best developers doing
today.
Also, I would
encourage-- so many
of you we're already
working with.
For any developers that are in
the audience today that are not
yet working with the
Play Games BD team,
I would definitely encourage
you to check out this link,
g.co/play/gamesBD.
So it's a quick form.
We review every
single submission
we get into this form.
And we're trying to manage
more and more developers.
But we will ask
you for some data.
We can't manage
every single person,
but we want to manage as
many of you as possible.
So that's the quick intro part.
Just to get into store
listing experiments,
it's something that we're
very, very excited about.
It's been a very successful
product for us overall.
And so here was Congregate and
their game Epic Skater here.
We launched this product
at Google I/O last year.
And this is the game
we launched with.
As you can see here,
they initially started
with that top icon
and then moved
to the yellow icon
down at the bottom
on the basis of their use
of Google Play Store listing
experiments.
If you go to the major
mobile app stores today,
you will find that that
yellow icon is still
the Epic Skater icon
across all of those stores.
And so the developer is
getting that return on the work
that they did a year
ago, and it continues
to pay dividends
for them in terms
of higher conversion even now.
Another developer
that we worked with,
Dots, took a really
analytical and really cool
approach to breaking down
all of the different elements
of the Play Store listing page.
And so you can see here
that on the left side
the icon was the most impactful
change that they made.
It was around 8% lift on
impressions to installs.
You can look though-- this
actually does multiply across.
And so while each individual
element in this case
was about an 8% in the most
case, across all of it,
you're getting a 30%
plus lift across all
these different elements.
And so by using this tool,
you can get a big lift.
And then get back to Congregate.
So on the basis of the
success in Epic Skater,
they decided to move
on to other games,
including Global
Assault. This chopper
icon has become
somewhat famous now
within our team for a 91% lift.
And one thing that I
really want to point out
that's really
fascinating about this
is, beyond just the numbers,
when you look at that control
icon, before using
Play Store Experiments,
Congregate had actually
tested that control
icon in another
test, and it had won.
And so the difference was
that, before using Play Store
Experiments, the only
way for Congregate
to test this icon was to do
media buys across ad networks.
But that's a
different environment.
The best way to
test your icon is
in situ in the context
of the Play Store,
because that's the environment
in which somebody makes
that install decision, to
see it and decide whether
or not to install.
And so it's a
really powerful way
to directly integrate
experiments.
And they'd be testing directly
into the Play Store itself.
And so these are some really
good examples of experiments.
We've shared some
of these before.
One thing we haven't
talked about previously
though is Monster Strike and
its international expansion.
And so I'm sure many of you are
familiar with Monster Strike.
It's an extremely
popular game in Japan,
but not been as success
in other markets.
But they used the Google
Play Store Experiments
to help them expand into
the US market in particular.
And this is probably
my favorite slide
of the presentation,
where it demonstrates
that over the course
of a couple months,
Mixi was able to make a 68%
improvement in their conversion
based on a lot of
different experiments.
And so you can see
here that there
are dots that are colored
a bunch of different ways.
And they were testing various
elements of their Play Store
listing page that
I'll go into in more
detail in the future slides.
But this was a really
successful experiment for them
that encouraged them
actually to invest further
into localization for this game.
And so again in
this case, the icon
did have the
biggest improvement.
We found that
dragons-- cultures have
different interests in terms of
what a dragon should look like.
The Japanese dragon
can be different
from a Western dragon, in this
case, a bit more aggressive,
making eye contact.
And so changing to
this more Western style
had a big impact in this game.
Also, here's the
short description.
The short description
was changed as well.
And that also had a big impact.
Remembering back to that slide
on Dots, where they broke down
the different elements
of conversion,
while the icon had the biggest
impact in the case of Dots,
the short description and
that changed optimization
had the second biggest impact.
And so this can also
make a really big change
for your games.
And then third, your screenshot.
So you can see here
really emphasizing
the ricochet mechanic, which is
the core mechanic of the game,
through all of
these screenshots,
and also focusing on
a much cleaner style.
Mixi was really focused
on having a less busy
graphical style in this game.
And so these screenshots
really bring out
how it's a more Western
style in this game.
In the screenshots, going
back to that Dots' example,
Dots had found that it was
the third biggest impact.
And so getting a sense
of what you're changing
and the relative
impact of this, you
can find these things out
by using store listing
experiments.
Finally, for the
Play Store elements,
changing the video as well
too, its another element.
The Play Store has emphasized
video for a long time.
You could see from Morgan's
talk that we're adding
playable units as well too.
But video is very important
to get higher conversion.
And then not just
from the Play Store--
this is another
interesting thing,
where, based on
the success, Mixi
continued to evolve their
Play Store listing elements,
but then also went into deeper
localization in the game
itself.
And so here you can see the
start screen, which, again,
emphasizes that ricochet.
It is a much more cleaner style.
If you're familiar with the
Japanese version of the game,
it's a lot busier and focuses
on many, many characters.
And then finally, in terms
of the start screen here,
so you have a much
more Western style.
And they're emphasizing a lot
of the core visual elements.
And so this is a
big success, where
Mixi, just on the basis of
initially using Play Store
listing experiments,
has really broadened
the audience for their game.
If you're like
me-- they actually
launched a lot of these
changes last month.
Monster Strike is a
great game, but it
had been kind of hard for me,
as an American, to play it.
But I've been into it a lot
more over the last month
now that they made
these changes.
So I'd encourage you guys
to check it out again.
And this is the last
part of this slide.
But just really saying
that having experiments
directly built into the
platform was really powerful.
It's a really key
advantage and allows
them to have rapid iteration
in terms of the changes
they're making.
And so this is a
really great example
for the power of this product.
Next, going into
pre-registration.
And so this is another product
that we launched originally
last year that has some
limited availability
but is showing some really
positive initial steps.
And when I think about
pre-registration,
I think about big game launches.
And so one of the trends
in the industry right
now is towards fewer, bigger.
When you talk to a
lot of developers,
what feels like the
dominant strategy right now
is to focus more of your
resources, more of your team's
energy into a fewer
number of games
and really emphasizing
on making them the best
they can possibly be.
And so not just
focusing on your game
when it launches,
but definitely,
as Ben was talking about,
supporting your game
post-launch for hopefully
long periods of time.
But what
pre-registration is about
is supporting these games
even in the pre-launch period.
And so we'll talk
more about that.
Here, on our part
within Google Play,
we have a significant interest
in keeping the store fresh.
We talk a lot about somebody
comes to the Play Store,
and they don't want to
see just the same games
and the same apps
over and over again.
And so when we think about
a developer's interest
in promoting their game
before it actually launches
and our strong interest
in having a fresh store,
that's where pre-registration
comes into play.
And when we're choosing
to work with developers,
it's also important that
this be a partnership.
And so we're helping support
these games before they launch.
But it's very
important here, as you
can see, across promo unit
in Jelly or social support
in the case of
Clash Royale, we're
working together with developers
to amplify and magnify
these bigger launches.
We're seeing this trend
towards developers
focusing more attention
towards these big launches.
And we want to find the best
way to help them do that.
OK.
Cool.
All right.
And so just more
mechanically how
this works here--
so on the left you
can see that the
pre-registration button--
so where you would expect to
see an install button typically
within the Play Store, that will
be a pre-registration button.
And then on the
right, you'll see
that you'll be made aware that
the game will be available,
and you'll receive a
notification at launch.
And this is something,
again, that's very powerful.
We're looking for a lot
of the features that
are most powerful when
built into the store.
And so when I talked
about experiments,
and it's most
powerful whenever you
can test within the context
of the Play Store-- here,
one of the benefits that
you get of integrating
Play pre-registration
is the ability
to have people become aware of
the game whenever it launches.
And so just to repeat,
pre-registration
is still not fully
a public product.
We're very cautious
of the user experience
and making sure that the
games that start into Google
Play pre-registration, that
there's a really good user
experience and they
launch shortly afterwards.
But this is something that
we're interested in working
with more and more
developers in the future.
And this is another great
quote from Glu Mobile,
talking about the benefit
of pre-registration.
The key thing here is
a clear call to action.
And so developers
are doing press.
And they're doing PR.
They're doing marketing
advance of games.
But without a clear call to
action, you get a lot of loss
in terms of people
hearing about the game
but not necessarily
installing it at launch.
And so this is a
really helpful tool
to help people convert more of
their marketing into installs.
Cool.
Next, talking about
Play Games Services.
And so Play Games Services
is our global games network.
This is being used by a
very, very large population
of developers and players today.
And as we talked
about earlier, we're
integrating more and
more developer services
into Play Games Services.
And then there's other cool
programs, like the Indie
Corner, that we'd
announced, where
eligibility for the
Indie Corner requires
developers to integrate
Play Games Services.
And so you can think
of this game network
as the underlying
layer, upon which
we're going to build a lot of
other programs and developer
tools.
And just some of the tools that
I'll talk about in this context
today are the player stats
API, player analytics, and then
some of our video
recording features.
Some of these were
covered earlier.
But these are really important
ones, so I want to emphasize.
Again, talking about
what we, as the BD team,
are encouraging
developers to adopt,
these are some of the biggest
priorities that we see.
And so in terms of
the player stats API,
machine learning has been
a really hot and fun topic
at Google.
I don't know if anybody else
has been watching AlphaGo,
but it's been a lot of
fun over the last week.
And there's a lot
of machine learning
that's happening in
the context of Google
and this is our
ability to expose
some of those great
tools to more developers.
And so here, really
focusing on prediction.
Ben had talked a bit about this.
But churn prediction and spend
prediction is really powerful.
And so a lot of the
really cool technology
that Google is
building and developing
for generalized
uses in other cases,
we're applying that to Play Game
Services to the player stats
API.
And again, so the
Underwater Apps guys
are becoming a
bit of a favorite.
But this was really
powerful, where just
that ability for developers
of all sizes-- this is quite
a small developer--
to be doing more
advanced segmentation based
on prediction around spend.
And Ben had shared
some of these results
around a 15% increase in the
number of in-app purchase
transactions and a 17%
increase in the amount of ad
spend for advertising.
And so here, you
get this benefit
just by using Play
Games Services,
of having Google's machine
learning technology that you
can apply into your game.
And we think that
that's really powerful.
And then also, getting
into player analytics
reports-- and so I had
mentioned at the beginning
about retention curves
and how important that is.
I know that retention
can be hard.
There's a lot of different
ways to measure retention.
But player analytics includes
a retention report, which
is a good default. If
you're unsure how you're
measuring retention,
we strongly encourage
you to be using these reports.
And then the sources
and sinks report
gives you a sense of how much
currency you're generating
versus how much your
players are consuming.
Again, the Underwater Apps guys
had a lot of success with that.
And one of our hero developers
from last year, Bomb Squad,
also had a lot of success with
this sources and sinks report.
And so I encourage you to
check both of these out.
Again, as Ben had mentioned,
just with Max Games,
with this funnel
report on the left,
it's another more
recent report that we're
creating for developers that
we think has a lot of value.
And then on the right,
with cohorts as well too.
And so we want to talk with
more and more developers
about using these reports,
using these services
and getting your feedback
into what's working for you
guys, what's not.
We know that when you're getting
to running your business--
Keith has been great, trying
out a lot of our stuff.
And we want to be working with
more and more of all of you,
both in terms of managing
you, as well as working
with you on products like this.
And then finally, in the
Play Games Services part,
video recording is a
big opportunity for us.
Obviously, you see
YouTube here as part
of this, where, by combining
the size and power of Android
and Google Play, with
distribution through YouTube,
there's a ton of potential for
this product within a Google
context.
And so as you can see
here, this is a product
that we launched last year
initially through the context
of the Play Games app, where
you can see-- when this resets,
it will start.
So here's the beginning of
it-- where you press record,
you go into a game.
And then there, you count down.
And then you're
playing and narrating
over top of that optionally.
And then you're just editing in
YouTube and then sharing out.
And so it's pretty easy.
By combining Google Play
as well as with YouTube,
you can reach a
very large audience
by integrating the
video recording
products that we have.
We started by doing that through
the Google Play Games app.
And now, we've just
announced that we
have an API as well
too, where we already
have a couple developers who
have adopted that, including
Minecraft Story Mode and
Summer Wars as well too.
And so you'll start to
see the video recording
API integrated directly
into more and more games.
All right.
So almost done with this par.
So new technologies
and platforms.
After my session
now too, we're going
to have a bunch of
lightning talks.
They're great.
I encourage you guys to
stick around for all of them.
It's a really great format
that we started last year
and was just really
entertaining to watch for me.
I'll just touch on
some of these briefly,
but I just wanted to queue
up some of the topics
that we'll be talking about
in some of the lightning
talks with Vulkan, with Android
TV, and with our VR products.
So quickly on Vulkan-- so
we talked a bit about that.
But as a business
guy myself, it's
like, why is this relevant?
You saw the short tornado
piece, which is amazing.
But better performance
in your games
is obviously really valuable.
We're really focused
on not just all gamers,
but high end games is
increasingly a focus for us
too.
So we want to make sure
that there's-- Android is
for everybody.
And so it's going to be massive
reach in terms of casual.
But we also have people who
are dedicated to focusing
on high end gaming and
people who are really focused
on Vulkan in that context.
And then on just
having thinner drivers,
just having more
maintainability on your side.
So not relying on driver vendors
to update their software,
but giving more control to the
game developers themselves,
so that you don't need
to deal with differences
across the hardware ecosystem.
So there's a lot
of value to Vulkan.
And we're supporting
that in Android
in a standards-based way.
And so we're very
excited about its future.
Next onto Android TV,
where Nathan Camarillo will
talk about our
living room products
in general in the
lightning talks.
So in terms of the
progress we've made,
so great partnerships
with Sony, Sharp, Philips,
various other service providers.
For us, when we look at
the majority of Android TV
deployments to date, it's
been more casual gaming
style, D-Pad games.
And so with Pewdiepie,
Legend of the Brofist here
and then Disney
DuckTales, here's
some examples of some
of the earlier games
that have come to
the Android TV.
And so I encourage
you to stick around
for Nathan's lightning talk
on this topic later on today.
And then this is an example
too of the high end.
And so Borderlands the
pre-sequel is actually
coming at the high end.
So it's one of the great
things about Android
of having that diversity of
these very casual franchises,
but also these core games, these
high end games as well too.
And so we're able
to stretch to reach
both of those in the
context of our living room
products and Android TV.
Then finally, just
a quick shout out.
We've got a lot of smart people
within Google working on VR,
and Nathan Martz is one of them.
And he's going to
give a quick lightning
talk on our VR efforts later on
in the lightning talk session.
And so that's it for my section.
I just really enjoyed
sharing all of this with you.
We really enjoy GDC,
where it's an opportunity
to reconnect with a
lot of familiar faces,
but also meet a bunch of people.
So all of the people
who were around earlier
will stick around.
Thank you for spending the
time with us this morning,
and I encourage you to stay
for the lighting talks as well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]